every game by from software starts with
a cinematic trailer and this is surely
elden rings it happened an age ago
she's talking about the shattering of
the olden ring an entire age has passed
since then
but when i recall i see it true
this character with forearms and this
brittle pale skin
was a witness on a night of wintry fog
in a shot that's surely inspired by lord
of the rings four shrouded riders flee
the scene
and if you played the network test you
might have even faced one of them at
night on a bridge this exact same
shrouded horse and rider can be found
and fought
the rule of death was stolen
but here is where things get interesting
so runes are letters of a runic alphabet
and in fantasy you know they're often
markings of great power the olden ring
is actually made up of runes its tiniest
pieces are a currency like souls but its
larger shards are called great runes and
they are far more significant
together these great runes of the elden
ring spell out a golden order for the
world japanese descriptions clarify that
it's a golden law it's a logic for life
to follow
now this golden order is broken to its
core and it all began when the rune of
death was stolen so what specifically
was the rune of death and why was its
theft important enough to spark the
shattering
well i think items in the network test
actually hold the clue in olden ring
there's an item called a holy pot it's
something you can peg it undead enemies
to prevent them from rising after death
it reads incantations of the golden
order or golden law
have been stored inside the golden law
has no mercy for those who trespass
beyond life's bounds and its japanese
description clarifies that the golden
law does not permit the logic to live in
death
so with the rune of death stolen from
the elden ring nothing is keeping the
dead in their graves anymore that law
doesn't bind undeath proof of this is in
so much of the present game spirits are
found all throughout the lands between
skeletons stand up from their graves
even you the tarnished you're called ye
dead who yet live
in response to this lawless world
a group has even risen called the golden
order fundamentalists they're people who
try to enforce the old laws of the elden
ring one of their spells is litany of
proper death
it's an incantation that prevents undead
enemies from coming back to life so this
golden law can still be applied it's
just not a universal truth anymore while
the elden ring was still whole and its
laws were intact the lands between were
ruled by queen america the eternal her
being eternal suggests that the olden
ring wasn't applying death to the queen
or her demigod children
now that seems set to change
because the rune of death has been
stolen
and the demigods began to fall
surely it's no coincidence that only now
death is being served to america's
demigod children a thief holds the rune
of death and it's being used
starting with godwin the golden
in dark souls all of gwyn's children
start with the same name prefix you know
gwyndolin guinevere so on just so all of
queen america's children appear to have
names that start with the god prefix so
far we know of two others there's godric
a demigod boss at the end of stormville
castle
godfrey who we haven't seen yet but who
ruled over his own age and now there's
godwin the golden a shadow looms over
godwin and it kind of looks like a
person holding a large weapon when they
retreat they take the light with them
and in the darkness emerging from the
strangely shaped wound on his back this
writhing force under his skin worms its
way around their body and towards their
eyes with this godwin seems to live
again after death as we mentioned
earlier and death is possible now though
we have no idea who he serves and while
all of this is going on
queen mariko was driven to the brink but
she doesn't seem to have been killed yet
we as tarnished are even able to
resurrect at her statues which to me
suggests that she's still a force in the
world and that she has an affection or
at least a use for the tarnished
in the scene to follow a crown is set
upon an empty throne i say it's hers
because this main throne is surrounded
and faced by five maybe six other
smaller thrones
these likely belong to each of her
demi-god children
but her throne itself is embossed with
countless depictions of the urgery and
we need to mention the odd tree briefly
because it is a symbol of queen
america's power way more than the elden
ring is in my opinion the age before the
shattering is called the age of the odd
tree after all it's not called the age
of the elden ring
the elden ring is at the source of the
earth tree's power and it's the erd tree
and america's family that seems to
direct that power delivering golden
grace to certain folk in the lands
between and spurning others
but again we talk about that more in a
different video
this scene is clearly meant to symbolize
an absence of that power now that the
shattering war has begun and the last to
leave this throne room is margaret the
fel omen this is clearly him he's the
main boss in eldon rings network test
he's the guardian of stormville castle
and now perhaps he's also a servant of
america's royal family
the olden ring twitter revealed that the
curse marks he bore from birth were
another ominous sign for the royal
family so this proves that he was close
to them and it explains his name
margaret was a fel omen for america's
royal family he was a sign of the
terrible things to come the shattering
ensued a wall that wrought only darkness
the elden ring was broken
[Music]
but by whom
and why
so whoever broke the olden ring hasn't
publicly revealed themselves even now
they might not have even made a play for
its power it follows then that they're
perfectly happy to just watch chaos
unfold the great rune of death is just
one part of the puzzle remember imagine
how many other laws have been thrown
into disarray
now these estranged demigods hold other
great runes and they're warring amongst
each other so why interfere
what could the demigods ever hope to win
by boring
this scene is so incredible the absolute
scale of it under the shadow of a very
sad looking herd tree is a fortress that
has statues of tree sentinels which is
this boss from the network test
besieging this castle is a force that
would be familiar to you if you played
the network test these soldiers and
giants are all seen throughout limgrave
and the lion heraldry on these soldiers
marks them as warriors of godric one of
america's demigod children and the ruler
of stormvale castle he's clearly waging
a war here against a city of the erd
tree which is surely a place that would
have been his former home
according to the elden ring twitter
godric was born a weakling child and he
coveted the strength of his kin his
kingdom is still at war long past the
shattering and he clings to his ruined
legacy the ruler of a husk rung dry by
war clearly he wields a lot of power but
that power is waning godric's claim as
the rightful golden king is not wholly
uncontested there are those who plot to
see his crown pass into more worthy
hands so even after the shattering
powerful individuals still remain
like these two
[Music]
the conqueror of the stars
general time
first thing here very important
general redan has a goddamn horse
between his legs did you notice that
that is one sad horse lucky for the
horse i guess uh radhan appears to have
power over gravity when you cast spells
in eldon ring the class of spell is
actually revealed by a symbol that pops
up and the symbol for gravitational
sorcery is revealed here and look it's
the exact same symbol that is embossed
onto his blades the purple glow between
his blades is even the same purple that
gravitational sorcery gets for example
just look at the meteorite spell the
meteorite item description reads
meteorites held the same import as stars
and radar is clearly capable of
channeling that cosmic power remember
the first trailer we ever saw
that which commanded the stars
the olden ring commanded the stars and
general radar conquered them i guess
that would make him a warrior of the
elden ring but we can't be sure yet
stars are so important to elton ring's
law and in another video we'll talk
about the age of cosmic power that came
before the age of the odd tree but for
now just know that this age did exist
long ago before the olden ring commanded
the stars anyway back to the shattering
these two were the mightiest to remain
and locked holes in combat
he hacks off melania's prosthetic arm
but she snatches the blade that was
attached to that arm out of thin air and
uses her own body weight to force it
deeper into radan's flesh while doing
this i notice she's muttering something
an incantation maybe i do think it's
melania who summons this orange lotus
that sneaks in from behind her envelops
her and appears to teleport her away
perhaps
but there would be no victor
[Music]
we get to fight melania later on so
obviously she survives this encounter
but i'm not so sure that radon does
while the dialogue implies that neither
of them loses this fight remember in the
first trailer we saw radan get struck by
this lance knight on horseback and then
later we see him standing with life
energy sort of pouring out of him so
maybe there's more to this cutscene that
we haven't yet seen
but for now here's the finale
and so we inhabit a fractured world
this character is the storyteller wait
that's my job
anyway on her right is a projection of
herself it speaks at the same moment she
does it's a mirror image that shares her
right eye and what's fascinating about
this is that melaner our maiden also has
a closed eye with a marking
some people have pointed out that this
marking is on melaner's left eye whereas
this storyteller has the marking on her
right eye but remember the melanoma we
see is an apparition she's a spirit she
appears out of a blue ghostly form which
means that she might actually be closer
to this phantom storyteller rather than
the real one therefore the marking on
the real melanoma might have actually
been on the right side just like it is
for the storyteller if that makes sense
anyway her saying that the world has
been fractured in this scene is likely
not a coincidence you know characters
like melaner and this storyteller are
stuck in a sort of limbo between life
and death they are fractured they have
spirit versions of themselves
[Music]
unless of course
thou should take the crown
the last thing the storyteller suggests
is that we might take the crown and the
title of the elden lord
now i have two upcoming lore videos that
talk about melania's eye marking and
what the title of elden lord means and
so so much more the law of elden ring is
so fascinating look at the mind map i've
made there's already so much here to
discuss and understand so please do
subscribe because i can't wait to share
it with you
if you're a three dollar patron keep an
eye out i'll be uploading these lore
videos in early access very soon so if
that's something you'd like to see early
consider becoming a patron but if not
subscribe because these videos should be
edited and available for everyone in a
couple of weeks i'll see you then i'm
gonna go sleep now
[Music]